pour toi
l'écran d'un téléviseur a remplacé la
toile
ouais ouais
parce que rien d'autre que des jeunes moyens
ils font de la peinture de première année sur ordinateur
ouais donc
mais tu es le premier à faire ça maintenant
et je suis content d'avoir gagné parce que
tout le monde pensait
j'étais fou quand tu étais enfant en
corée tu
regardes la télé regarde je suis né en 1932 il n'y avait pas de télé
même en amérique
tu sais donc on avait une radio grosse radio
ouais et puis alors
j'ai pensé bien tu sais que le gars parlait
à l'intérieur de la radio
boîte c'était 1935 ou alors tu sais alors j'ai dit
pourquoi cet oncle ne sort jamais de la
boîte
et cette fois tu es un musicien avec qui tu
as travaillé euh ouais
ouais nous j'étais le seul à
arnold chamber tu connais la musique alors je
tu étudiais tu sais et
mon professeur était communiste il est allé au
nord à l'extérieur
et de l'autre côté tu travaillais avec
stockhausen ouais tu étais musicien
et comment es-tu devenu interprète
parce que j'étais un mauvais compositeur donc tu devais
faire quelque chose
tu as rencontré john  cage ouais ouais ouais qu'est
-ce qu'il a apporté  à toi
parce qu'il m'a donné le courage d'être libre
ouais
ouais et puis à cause de ça j'étais
tu sais
j'ai détruit le piano j'ai fait des femmes nues
ou n'importe quoi tu sais tout devient
musique alors il a été pour moi des initiations tu
sais
permis de tuer et quoi  était flexus
lux est une plaisanterie pour les jeunes qui veulent
être
un complexe du monde de l'art du musée extérieur
maintenant quand vous êtes des artistes, vous devez obtenir
les commandes de la galerie de la galerie
, puis vous essayez de mendier
le musée d'art moderne
mais nous étions environ 20
vous savez  jeunes artistes du monde entier
nous avons fait du thai international
et nous voulons créer notre propre monde artistique
tu sais
tu dis que si james joyce était encore en
vie
tu aurais écrit finn contre wake
en vidéo ouais bien sûr je veux dire déjà
john kege écrit tous ses textes  sur le traitement de
texte ouais donc c'est toujours la
réalité
quels artistes aimeriez-vous avoir
si vous n'étiez pas
namjoon bake oh je pense que
martin de chang est assez intéressant
ouais
tu sais que tu as été très inspiré par lui
oh  ouais ouais ouais et puis j'en ai eu
un en fait je l'ai vu trois fois ouais
tu l'as rencontré
ouais pas rencontré je l'
ai vu trois fois par hasard et je connaissais sa
femme mais je n'ai jamais eu le courage de lui parler
et je l'ai regardé attentivement ouais  il est
très garanti qu'il
a beaucoup influencé le monde aussi lui et
influence ouais bien sûr il a influencé
tout le monde
ouais es-tu occupé ouais copié tu
sais je copie
et ils copient tu sais que nous sommes
sans information tu sais que l'
information doit circuler ouais et aussi
tu copie honnêtement
tu sais pour ne pas tricher c'est bien ouais comme le
ping pong  soyez libre ouais parce que la
télévision est gratuite
comprenez ce qui devrait coûter moins de cinq
dollars si une définition de vous
devait rester dans le dictionnaire des
artistes ouais
quelle définition aimeriez-vous
avoir oh
je suis un créateur fou coréen
fou et le  n coréen et coréen,
il est très important pour vous d'être coréen
ouais parce que j'aime être coréen parce que les
coréens
sont le
peuple khan vous savez qu'ils n'ont pas seulement
tué des gens mais ils étaient d'
est en ouest ils ont ouvert la route d'
est en ouest donc  que
marco poro peut venir à pékin tu sais
tellement jingiskan à sa manière très brutale les
communicateurs est-ouest tu sais et
ils sont la normal c'était comme marco
polo mais d'une
autre manière ouais ouais parce que ça a rendu
le marco polo
possible ouais alors  alors euh
parce que j'aime aussi m'identifier aux
personnes les plus faibles tu sais que la corée est faible et
petite et je veux toujours être
avec des outsiders tu sais je ne
veux pas être américain ou français est
ce que tu regardes la télévision je
veux dire je n'ai pas la télé  vraiment nous vivons
dans le bâtiment en fonte de
sorte que vous ne pouvez pas regarder la télévision vous n'avez pas de télévision
vous n'êtes pas habitué à regarder la télévision
pas vraiment certains si si je suis dessus
je dois aller à l'autre endroit pour
me regarder trois ouais
ferme les yeux et  Je veux dire, je ne suis pas
contre la télé juste  la télé est
lente ouais généralement le tempo est lent
pour ouvrir les yeux en troisième
la capacité de gérer les gens
le brillant directeur de ma campagne pour
la présidence
comme étant l'un des meilleurs experts en
crédits de défense
donc vous n'aimez pas la télé j'aime la télé mais
vous  sais que je n'ai jamais eu l'argent pour acheter mes
propres téléviseurs quel est
le programme que vous préférez je veux dire je préfère
votre programme de pairs
l'inaudible